actually pretty good but there's so much
stuff like we have sidewise we are we
are our YouTube sensation charles 29
asked what universities we put down as
options on UK si put Oxford Durham
Manchester Leeds Warwick and all
statistics okay and I needed um Oxford
York LSE UCL and Warwick not over and
that was for a range of PPE at Warwick
pop serving Gork and then UCL was
philosophy and economics and then LSE
was government and economics and I
actually would drew my application from
UCL because I didn't want to go there
and because I got the offer from altered
and I had an exam the day they wants me
come for an interview I didn't even go
to my dorm interview oh it's really fun
how did we choose I mean I chose based
on I basically chose based on the course
I go on know how great the course was I
discovered P P and then I discovered
where you could go to study PPE and I
was convinced by the structure of the
course and the flexibility gave you on
the insights that gave you into the wild
so I was like okay only to find places
that also offer this and the standard
places for that are Oxford Warwick York
and then I found other ones near London
because I'm from London it just made
sense the pick plates I was near to hide
yeah I mean I chose physics because I it
was actually it was the moment in GCSE
when scientist split from just you to go
science lessons to doing you know
physics chemistry biology and all the
cool stuff was in physics so I was like
alright that's what I want to do so I
just kind of I did that and I looked up
I think I was a bit naive intense that I
largely looked up based on the leave
tables and I chose the institutions
visited a couple I don't I also didn't
apply to anything too close to home so I
didn't apply to Bristol or bath because
I'm I live pretty much acquiesced to
between those two even though they're
both very good for physics I just didn't
want to be too close to home I don't be
so close that I could visit every
weekend basic
helped it grow as a person absolutely
are asked you to sign them what was your
pact school so my leap at school oh yeah
this is a while ago um it was about 70
but the thing with path is that it
varies year by year the the mean moves
quite a bit every year so that's pretty
much meaningless unfortunately it was
good enough for me to get an interview
who's good enough for me to get in but
um yeah that's not actually very much
help so Jamie you were also asking the
same question had ever looked into Vic
understand yes I have looked into
visions time work and I highly recommend
but you search on YouTube
Vic and Stein lectures and then go to
the first playlist it's a fantastic
introduction into Vic consigns work the
history of [ __ ] Stein and then
earlier the consignor none later Vic and
signed as well the interesting stuff
happens and he was fantastic for so
those looking into the philosophy of
language so how do we use language and
what is actually the meaning of language
when we're trying to communicate what
our world around us is that's a very
crude summary of what we can sign does
is he's fascinating check them out
Emilia Emilia Raymond Yost is better to
apply before getting on a level or back
results for deferred entry or after
getting them why sort of we should
discuss this yes they wrote I said that
you should do both because um you need
to bounce like having two opportunities
to apply is increases your chances more
than just having one opportunity to
apply and then in before getting your
grades you have this potential buffer of
like the prediction of the future so if
you don't meet it um then you've still
got the next opportunity to do I'm
explaining that very well but
essentially you have two chances as
opposed to one to apply both yeah but I
just agree okay next question makes
mathematical sense guten who tongue
galtung good job go Josh up Gaudete Go
Go Diego today yesterday good girl
tongue Mahapatra braver than me okay
said do you any of the departments
compete with each other is that why he
says ie the age-old feud between
geography and physics
think that's more geography and
everywhere else to be honest I think
everyone bashes geography in the same
way that everyone Bosch is English for
not terrific what do I know they did in
my life okay so the only imagining I've
seen is just between math math math
magicians and physicists and they try to
see who is doing a more pure subject oh
yeah I mean that's pretty much daily
feed I see I think generally there's a
healthy amount of academic banter going
yeah that's it it's not a feud it's
academic banter no one dies 9 war I
think anymore that was that thing no it
was Merton I think where somebody died
like a couple of centuries ago which is
why they send the barrel of wine - baby
old every year
Oh Paul has asked how well did you do
before Alex and Howard do during Oxford
um define while yeah I think doing well
is an interesting concept I think I did
better if I am my definition I think I
did better before I went to Oxford that
I did there in terms of I can we define
better yeah I think I didn't I did more
things at what was a higher level
relative to you know that age than I did
in Oxford and that's my own fault
because in Oxford I did nothing but try
and work which is a terrible idea and
you should always try and do
extracurricular stuff because you you
actually work better funnily enough yeah
you do
you have less time to muck around zs
focus I mean you've you sort of exploded
on the Oxford scene yeah so I mean in
terms of the level in energy I put into
going to Oxford I definitely was more
successful when I went to Oxford than
before but I mean academically you need
to be pretty consistent but I wanted to
find success Morris how fulfilled I was
in terms of living with my life um and
yeah I got involved in tons of stuff
like my degree with last thing I was
concerned about I always just say I'm
pretty sure I can write two essays a
week and do all this other stuff so I
just force myself to be able to and I
definitely say life was way more fun
yeah then I put learned from the lesson
I'm now actually basically doing what
you did it undergrad in PhD for missed
anything scheduled yesterday nice like
wait why do you take brain
quite right Thank You Kristen hey Annie
are you okay Annie are you okay I think
it's a reference oh yeah okay are you
okay are you okay I need okay yeah yo
you're a smooth criminal
what extracurricular did you guys do
before University do you think they were
a major factor that helped you get into
Oxford now I can answer that one
relatively assuredly assuredly because
of sort of I talked with the admissions
team in my college or law
the thing with extracurricular
activities is they are a big help to
your application if they are directly
relevant to your subject so for example
if you were really passionate about
speaking French and you went off to
France for a year on a gap year before
you know you were applying to study
physics that's not going to help talk
whereas obviously it would help if you
apply and study French or so if you go
to Cambridge modern medieval languages
but if you were doing I don't know if
you had if you found in your own
rocketry Club and you're applied for
physics that's gonna be a big help
because yeah any extracurricular
activity demonstrates things like time
management motivation that kind of thing
but it has to be relevant to what you're
doing it's um it's got to demonstrate
you take your passion your understanding
of your subject beyond the curriculum so
you know yes it I think it was a big
mass of me because I did an extended
project on space travel which I think
was a big influence and I think the
debating stuff which I did it actually
helped me a lot in interviews but it to
be honest dad hey you shouldn't be
getting hung up about it people seem to
have this idea you have yeah though it's
like you don't have to do any specific
thing like if I tell you go to Duke of
Edinburgh or someone help you get in
like in itself it won't contribute rocks
if it fills the criteria Simon Says yeah
sure I'm the licious yeah which we
marked for it but other universities it
is more important because they don't
interview you necessarily so they have
less information to go on so they'll go
more in your personal statement um so
it's it I think it is important we to do
extra curriculars just for life yeah but
also for apply for other universities
but for Oxford not so important I was
head boy knows dude if son right uh and
then
there's like time management stuff no it
was really related to my degree but it
showed I could juggle four heels and
then doing head boy as well and then I
also ran in my MA collection at school
in 2010 which was helpful for politics
and then aside from that I just did
later reading over the summer yeah
that's pretty much it
officially I think my new favorite
username on my channel Alexi metal
pirate axe question I'll be right along
where it's got numerous questions one
what you nervous about the workload of
uni and the difficulty the examples
before you even got there it'll work yes
no oh really well so everyone thinks
that they're a fluke right when they
arrive at opposite yeah and I was like
okay I need to worry upon arriving on
the day and I was like I'm a fluke oh
great there's no point worrying exams
they were so far away but upon getting
the first deadline which was Sunday of
freshers week like what yeah I assume
everyone was in the same boat I was like
okay good at least it's not just me
I might still be a fluke but at least
everyone else is thinking the same thing
and everyone else is like crud we need
to get this deadline done in like two
days
yeah on something we've never studied
before I have a site I did the very
strongest thing I did the stupid thing
of saying oh you're at the bottom of the
pile
you're going to get a box and you're
literally gonna be like the worst witch
of the physics course so just deal with
it and it turns out that that's not true
and it turns out the thinking like that
is actually quite corrosive because if
you think you're bad at a subject you'll
probably turn out to be bad at your
subject yeah so um I was very worried
and I was wrong to be worried so don't
be Alexi metal pirate X and then go a
second question how does it jump in
difficulty level between years
University you can bed to Jesus EAS a2
now I think this actually not talked
about very much I think the difficulty
to jump from a two from a to a 2 from a
s is bigger than a s from GCSE for one
thing yeah like and I wasn't prepared
for that I said you're in year 12
brace yourself for what's happening in
year 13 but I thought there wasn't a
colossal jump for the physics course
because they kind of eased you in okay
because not everybody did further maths
or as I did and the first four weeks
they did the a level in further maths in
those four weeks basically so those
first four weeks are like a ramp up for
me but after that obviously it's a bit
more but you might have got used to it
at that point I would save the questions
about University right yeah yeah yeah
okay cool so the thing that your
question doesn't acknowledge is that the
jump from a two to first year at uni
that is gigantic like it's huge and you
adjust to that pretty quickly you don't
think you will but then you'll realize
well I can get all of the stuff done the
jump in first year the second year and
then third year second and third you are
very similar in that you then have two
years to do all your papers at least
with PPE um and the jump in difficulty
is about the same I guess from Asda - I
don't know physics I didn't notice I
actually found first year by far and
away the hardest like I get got easier
for me until fourth year it got easier
and easier and then in for Thea the
difficulty to jumped up but I guess my
answer on using a bonus because in
second or third I was doing the papers I
really really wanted to do whether first
I was forced to do the describe papers
no because everyone needs have some
foundation also in physics the first
year is half mass and I'm not a
mathematician his heads doing a PhD in
maths okay not actually a mess on a
pretend mathematician right I want to
pronounce this next name yeah sure um so
I'm just compared on the screen sorry